in quantum mechanics particles are
things we only see when we measure them
but how they move around is described by
a wave function a wave function that
satisfies the schrodinger equation
which i talked about in my last video
it's important to note that wave
functions are not unique to quantum
mechanics we use wavefunctions in many
other systems like the motion of ripples
of water
sound waves vibrations on a string or
electromagnetic waves
and each of these systems has their own
wave equation which all have
similarities
as they all express the change of the
wave function in space and time
but the key difference between all of
these waves is that the quantum wave
function isn't a real physical wave
there is no medium like water or
electromagnetic field that's wobbling
so we can't say that quantum waves are
real with our current knowledge because
we can't measure them directly
but they do describe the behaviors of
quantum particles very well
so there must be something real going on
the question of whether
the wave function is real or not is a
big question veering into the
interpretations of quantum mechanics
so i'll just refer you to my previous
video on that subject
but even though we'll never be able to
see a quantum wave function
we can do the next best thing and
visualize the mathematical equations
so this is what the math says the wave
function looks like
these two are mathematically equivalent
although this one's easier to do
calculations with
but we'll use this form for this video
as it's easier to visualize
this wave function depends on time and
one dimension of space which is a
simplification from
a real particle which exists in three
dimensions of space
but this simplification allows us to
plot this function
so let's do that we'll just plot the
first part of this wave function to
begin with
this is simply a cosine wave note that
the k
is a variable controlling the size of
the wavelength the omega controls the
oscillation frequency
and the prefactor a controls the
amplitude so different parameters will
make different waves
now to plot the second part of the wave
we're going to need another axis
even though the wave is one dimensional
this is because the sine part of the
wave function is multiplied by the
imaginary number i
making it a complex wave function so
here they are both plotted independently
but if we plot the whole thing together
we get this
a spiral of complex values which would
go from minus infinity to plus infinity
but i'm just plotting a section of it
here
this is fixed at one point in time but
if we turn time on we get an oscillation
which
in this case manifests as a winding of
the spiral
so that's what a quantum wave function
looks like but what actually
is it it's called a probability
amplitude
and isn't anything physical on its own
but if you take the mod squared of the
amplitude it tells you the probability
of finding the particle at any point in
this one-dimensional space
so we can extract the position of a
particle from this wave function
actually the wave function doesn't just
tell you about the probability of
position but
all other measurable physical quantities
like momentum or energy or spin
we just need to do different
mathematical operations on the wave
function for each one
but overall the wave function is a
mathematical tool which keeps track of
all of the properties of a quantum
particle
and explains our observations of the
probabilistic nature of where particles
appear when we do experiments on them
so far i've given you one example of a
wave function but there are many other
possibilities
they just have to satisfy a set of
constraints which i'll be drawing on one
axis for clarity
firstly a wave function must be a
solution of the schrodinger equation
which i mentioned at the beginning
secondly when you calculate a
probability from the wave function
you'll get a probability distribution
and the area of this needs to equal 1
because there has to be a definite
probability you'll find the particle
somewhere
this means that the original wave
function can't have an infinite area
underneath it
technically we say that the wave
function must be normalizable
so my visualization from earlier is not
actually allowed because it goes from
minus infinity to plus infinity
to be valid it would have to go to zero
as x goes to infinity
thirdly the wave function must be single
valued
also it must be continuous so have no
breaks in it
and the slope of the wave function must
be continuous so no discontinuities in
the gradient like this
so those are the conditions quantum wave
functions have to meet
finally let's look at superposition this
is a property that's also not unique to
quantum mechanics
if you have two sets of ripples and
water that overlap any point will feel
the two waves added together
and this is a superposition of waves in
quantum mechanics if you have two or
more wave functions
that have valid solutions of the
schrodinger equation then any
combination of these wave functions is
also a valid solution
and this is where the idea comes from
that schrodinger's cat can be dead and
alive at the same time
although this never actually happens
because of other quantum phenomena
entanglement and decoherence these are
beyond the scope of this video
but here's an excellent video on the
subject from sabine hosenfelder
for those of you who'd like to delve
deeper this video was made possible
thanks to the kind support
of my patrons on patreon and people
buying posters from my dftba store
i couldn't keep this channel alive
without your support thanks everyone and
thanks for watching
you